[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
live from the Academy Museum of Motion
Pictures in Los Angeles please welcome
the president of the Academy David Rubin
good morning and welcome to the
brand-new David Geffen theater at the
Academy Museum we can't wait until the
museum officially opens later this year
when the world can experience in person
a sweeping adventure into the greatest
movies and movie makers of all time
we're here this morning to announce
nominations for the 92nd Oscars all the
nominees are voted on by members of the
Academy an international community of
artists
what makes this Oscar so special is that
these nominations are given to artists
by their peers actors nominate actors
editors nominate editors directors
nominate directors you get the idea and
now I'm pleased to introduce this
morning's hosts Issa Rae and John Cho
[Music]
but we decided that all people really
want to hear is who is nominated so
let's get started members of the
Academy's actors branch nominate these
performances by an actress in a
supporting role Kathy Bates in Richard
Jewell yes laura dern in marriage story
Scarlett Johansson in Jojo rabbit
Florence Pugh in Little Women and Margot
Robbie in bombshell to achievement in
costume design the members of the
Academy's costume designers branch
nominate the Irishman jojo rabbits joker
little women and once upon a time in
Hollywood Congrats yeah the soundbridge
overseas two categories for achievement
and sound mixing the branch nominates ad
astra Ford versus Ferrari Joker 1917
and once upon a time in Hollywood these
are the nominees for achievement in
sound editing Ford versus Ferrari Joker
1917 once upon a time in Hollywood and
star wars the rise of Skywalker my son
told me Star Wars or come home and shame
dead well here the nominees for Original
Score voted by the music branch Joker
little women marriage story 1917 and
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker we did
get it yep the short films and feature
animation branch overseas the short film
categories for best animated short film
here are the nominees Shara daughter
hair lobe kickball
memorable and sister I do not for Best
live action short film the branch
nominates Brotherhood nefta Football
Club the neighbors window Sariah
and a sister I don't act in category the
nominees for performance by an actor in
a supporting role are Tom Hanks in a
beautiful day in the neighborhood
anthony hopkins in the two popes Al
Pacino in the Irishman Joe Pesci in the
Irishman and Brad Pitt in Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood Wow bunch of no names
right there we still have more nominee
announcements we'll be back at exactly
5:30
[Music]
for those just joining man good morning
and for those watching welcome back you
already know it the Academy's
documentary branch oversees two
categories first the nominees for Best
Documentary Feature American Factory the
cave the edge of democracy and honey and
here are the nominees for Best
Documentary Short subject in the absence
learning to skateboard in a war zone if
you're a girl life overtakes me st.
Louis Superman and walk run ChaCha
and it missed through the best
collection of titles yeah
the newly renamed best international
feature film award is voted on by
Academy members across all branches from
around the world and the nominees are
Corpus Christi Poland
honey land North Macedonia women's Arad
France pain and glory Spain and
parasites South Korea the production
design branch nominates these films for
achievement and production design the
irishman jojo rabbit 1917 Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and parasites
I used to production design no way
I didn't yeah you lied to me God here
are the nominees for achievement in film
editing voted by the Academy's film
editors Branch Ford versus Ferrari the
Irishman
Jojo rabbit Joker and parasite great for
achievement in cinematography the
cinematographers branch nominates the
following films the irishman joker the
lighthouse 1917 once upon a time in
Hollywood you got this
we're doing great to do we're killing it
are we nominate us alright yeah ok that
talked the Academy's visual effects
branch nominates the following films for
achievement in visual effects avengers
end game the Irishman
The Lion King 1917 and Star Wars the
rise of Skywalker for achievement in
makeup and hairstyling the members of
this branch nominate the following films
bombshell Joker Judy
Maleficent mistress of eboard
and 1917 air show best animated feature
film is voted on by the shorts and
future animation branch as well as
members of the animation community
across all branches here are the
nominees How to Train Your Dragon the
hidden world
I lost my body Klaus
missing link and Toy Story 4 for
achievement in original song the music
branch nominates I can't let you throw
yourself away from Toy Story 4 I'm gonna
love me again from Rocket Man I'm
standing with you from breakthrough into
the unknown from frozen to band up from
Harriet the writers branch overseas two
categories first here are the nominees
for writing adapted screenplay
the Irishman Steven Zaillian jojo rabbit
Tycho ytt Joker Todd Phillips and Scott
silver little women Greta Gerwig and the
two popes Anthony McCartin and for
writing original screenplay the members
of the branch nominate knives out ryan
johnson marriage story Noah Baumbach
19:17 Sam Mendes and Christie Wilson
Cairns once upon a time in Hollywood
Quentin Tarantino and parasite bones you
know hon June 1 for performance by an
actor in a leading role the actors
branch nominates Antonio Banderas in
pain and glory Leonardo DiCaprio in Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood Adam driver in
marriage story
Joaquin Phoenix in Joker and Jonathan
Pryce in the two popes for performance
by an actress in a leading role the
actors branch nominates Cynthia areevo
in Harriet Scarlett Johansson in
marriage story
Saoirse Ronan in Little Women
[Music]
Charlize Theron's in bombshell Renee
Zellweger in Judy baby area for
achievement in directing the directors
branch of the Academy nominates the
irishman martin scorsese so her Todd
Phillips
19:17 Sam Mendes once upon a time in
Hollywood Quentin Tarantino and parasite
bong joon-ho and finally all voting
members of the Academy have nominated
the following films for Best Picture
Ford vs. Ferrari Peter Chernin jeno
topping and James Mangold producers the
irishman martin scorsese
Dero Jane Rosenthal and Emma Tillinger
Koskov producer
Jojo rabbit Carthew Neil and Tycho ytt
producers Joker Todd Phillips Bradley
Cooper and Emma Tillinger cough cough
producers little women Amy Pascal
producer Merrick story Noah Baumbach and
David Heyman producers 1917 Sam Mendes
Pippa Harris Jane and tendrán and Callum
MacDougall producers once upon a time in
Hollywood David Heyman Shannon Macintosh
and Quentin Tarantino producers and
parasite auction a and pum Juno
producers congratulations to all the
nominees thank you everyone for joining
us and watch the see who wins the gold
at the 92nd Oscars Sunday February 9 go
to bed guys
[Music]